your policy
against the islamic state has brought us
once again
to kill an american citizens under those
circumstances circumstances
under those circumstances cut
circumstances silicon sampsons
circumstances
circumstances and
paying over half of i mean billion
dollars
to a pr firm to create fake terrorist
videos
you okay five minutes under those
is circumcisions less circumstances this
is why
this is why we see you and your allies
the ionis
the only responsibles i said right
[Laughter]
right i saw that that was one of these
dozens and dozens and dozens of false
flag stories that we report on over at
false flag weekly news
and that's also well documented that's
not one that anybody is arguing didn't
happen
so the idea that terrorism is being used
clandestinely
this is why we see you
we see you and your allies that's
ionized the only responsible
of the killing of th
uh and and even the spectacle of
terrorism when maybe there isn't even
real terrorism
in some cases is being used to
manipulate public opinion
it really should be a no-brainer
if you want the killing to stop you give
us
10 million dollars change your name to
muhammad
[Music]
but because we're just pummeled
incessantly with the mainstream version
of things
people have been brainwashed into being
afraid to even go there
i mean we i i have to admit in every
you know bag of apples you got some
rotten ones
you do have some lunatics that you know
might attribute themselves to being
muslim
you know but anyone i like who's
sincerely practicing islam
and sees what it stands for these are
the things that really agitate and
aggravate you when
you you know really what islam is about
and then
you have to keep defending it against
these things that potentially don't have
even even if even if
all the muslims were doing drinking
alcohol for instance or eating pork or
being in just islam calls to be just
islam calls us stay away from evil
so you can't blame islam that's right is
that a good example you probably know if
the drunk driver crashes the
mercedes-benz you can't
blame the manufacturer right for the
drunk driver
but now we're going above and beyond and
we're saying hold on you will
many truth seekers out there who are
going down these rabbit holes are saying
like hold on
there's even more here right when you
start to uncover
the the history and we see that in
previous times certain things have been
uncovered then this thing half a billion
dollars on a pr firm fake videos
hello
i mean to do what to what's that all
about well it's it's it's even worse
than that eddie i mean that was one
example
but the it's isn't it bizarre that the
public relations agency that handles
isis videos is run by rita katz
the israeli intelligence agent uh it's
it's called site intelligence group
s-i-t-e
and it's a mossad spin-off so it's it's
basically an israeli operation
and yet we're told that essentially
every isis video
that is released goes through site
intelligence group
now many of these have been proven fake
action
you know over and over and over in fact
recently there's we discovered
that one of the worst supposed muslim
terrorists in the whole world
a guy named australia witness
supposedly operated online turned out to
be none other than joshua goldberg
the suspect rather that federal
investigators stopped from carrying out
a terror plot
here in kansas city this was published
in the sydney morning
herald and they have been tracking this
guy online joshua goldberg
a young jewish man operating out of his
basement in florida who's been
impersonating
evil muslim terrorists and evil white
supremacists and people like that
all over the world just like this new
guy in israel kadar that was just
arrested
an israeli teenager has faced court
accused of targeting victorian schools
with hoax bomb
and shooting threats he's alleged to
have made more than two thousand
calls as part of a worldwide campaign to
spread fear
and alarm michael cader is accused of
spreading terror across the globe
for thousands and thousands of threats
against jewish community centers
was actually a jewish israeli kid a
young man
whose uncle was a high up guy in israeli
black operations intelligence so we
we've seen so many of these cases
and but one of the things that really
aggravates me the most
is that they blame this on radical islam
on supposedly the more pious the muslim
the more dangerous
and this is the exact opposite of the
truth even if we accepted the official
story of let's say 911
then it it's these guys were not
pious they the people that were told
were the 19 hijackers there may have
been some identity theft there i don't
know
but they were you know their behavior
was the least islamic that you could
ever imagine and then that same pattern
repeats itself
over and over and over uh in so many of
these cases the patsies were blamed for
these supposed radical islamic attacks
are people with radically un-islamic
lifestyles there's stories you can't
believe the mastermind of the paris
attacks in november 2015
was uh in a car so he was they were all
drinking and
and smoking big joints and they got
pulled over as they were fleeing the
scene of the crime heading to belgium i
think it was
and the cops just let him go and waved
him on and and so what we're seeing in
these cases over and over is that these
patsies the the supposed radical muslims
who were set up to take the blame for
these things
are marginal characters they're kind of
low life characters often from muslim
backgrounds but very rarely serious
muslims
and they get involved with organized
crime drug trafficking the corrupt side
of the police establishment the
intelligence establishment
they get manipulated and they get set up
i think now we're going to take a break
but we we can get past the ad hominem
attacks many people start
you know attacking the person who wants
to bring up questions but i think now
we've proved something that
okay we can't trust this person whoever
is bringing these claims
we thought shown some examples through
history and then we gave the big example
of the just outright lie
of you know that bush with the whole
weapons of mass destruction which over
two million
innocent people over span of ten years
were killed
uh we should be a right have a right to
ask
some very important questions without
being labeled you know whatever
label i think is that a fair assumption
without i would name it
it's common sense